[Música]
rusia realizará maniobras militares
junto con china en el oriente del país
lo que muestra la cercanía entre estos
dos países en medio de las tensiones por
la invasión rusa en ucrania el
ministerio de defensa de rusia anunció
que el ejercicio llamado vostok 2022
tendrá lugar entre el 1 y 7 de
septiembre en el lejano oriente y el mar
de japón con más de 50.000 soldados 5000
equipos bélicos incluyendo 140 aviones y
60 buques las maniobras reflejan
entonces estos crecientes lazos de
defensa entre moscú y beijing que se han
fortalecido desde que rusia inició su
acción militar en ucrania por su parte
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
denunció que el apoyo estadounidense a
ucrania además de la visita a taiwán
hace de nancy pelosi son parte de una
campaña norteamericana para fomentar la
inestabilidad mundial eso dice el
presidente ruso saludamos entonces a
yago rodríguez él es analista militar y
director de política broma iago gracias
por estar con nosotros esta mañana de
martes aquí en directo américa de france
bético le pregunto qué busca rusia con
estos ejercicios en el este y qué tan
importante es esta cooperación militar
con china
bueno pues los ejercicios vostok que
efectivamente se llevan realizando desde
hace varios años son relativamente
típicos en ese sentido y lo que se busca
al final pues son dos cosas primero
simbolizar digamos la creciente alianza
entre chineros y especialmente a tenor
de la situación en ucrania y taiwán que
de alguna manera empuja a ambas
potencias a estar más cerca entre sí y
en segundo lugar pues para mejorar lo
que se conoce como las capacidades
combinadas esto es un ejército no deja
de ser una gran burocracia no sencillo
coordinar diferentes equipos con
diferentes sistemas y en este sentido al
realizar este tipo de ejercicios
demuestro que puedo coordinar a la
armada china con la armada rusa y en
este sentido pues si llega a haber algún
tipo de conflicto o alguna situación
en la que sea necesario que ambos actúen
a la vez os doy la imagen de que tienen
la posibilidad real de actuar a la vez
claro ya hago sin embargo pues estaba
también leyendo que desde que se
iniciaron estos ejercicios hace ya hace
hace ya unos años atrás estos que vienen
ahorita en septiembre tienen menor
presencia digamos de militar los
efectivos porque esta disminución
hombre como es natural y como supongo
que que todos podemos directamente
intuir el asunto de la guerra de ucrania
está absorbiendo todos los esfuerzos del
ejército ruso todas las unidades
operativas del ejército ruso que estén
en un estado de mantenimiento de
operatividad mínimo pues están siendo
enviadas a rusia mediante para ucrania
perdón mediante las líneas de
ferrocarril y por tanto lo que quede
ahora mismo en el extremo oriente pues
son las peores unidades con el peor
mantenimiento y en este sentido pues es
lógico que haya una reducción en el
número de efectivos y de medios
empleados en estos ejercicios militares
claro ya china sin embargo se ha negado
digamos a criticar pues frontalmente
esta acción de rusia la guerra en
ucraniano culpando a eeuu de l'estany
por es una provocación a moscú también
ha criticado a las sanciones pero porque
se han negado como que hablar
directamente sobre este tema porque esta
abstención también de china por los
intereses económicos digamos que tiene
con occidente
y hay varios asuntos de por medio pero
naturalmente para china hay aquí un gran
dilema al final china lo que quiere en
algún momento es superar a eeuu y ser la
principal potencia del planeta y en este
sentido claro si yo doy la imagen de que
apoyo un país que acaba de realizar una
invasión de otro que por tanto
compromete el equilibrio internacional
que pone en riesgo las relaciones
económicas pues hombre eso es un riesgo
no y además puede suceder que los países
europeos y eeuu decidan imponer
sanciones a la economía china que al
final es el motor de ese país por tanto
de un lado china no quiere implicarse
mucho en el asunto ucraniano sin embargo
de otro lado lo cierto es que rusia
comparte una enorme frontera terrestre
con china rusia es fundamental para que
china no pueda ser aislada es
fundamental que rusia nunca caiga en el
bando occidental y a partir de ahí cabe
decir que comparten pues las mismas
fricciones con actores similares en
taiwán y ucrania dos asuntos pues de
interés nacional muy claro para ambos
países por tanto de ahí viene la a veces
ambivalente postura de china aunque es
previsible que si el conflicto se alarga
vaya decantando no sé poco a poco a
intervenir indirectamente pero
intervenir de manera creciente en el
mismo claro a tomar ya digamos su
postura de frente también aunque moscú y
beijing han rechazado la posibilidad de
una alianza militar concreta entre estas
naciones pues también el presidente de
la jmas putin ha dicho que pues tampoco
está tan descartado de la mesa no hay
posibilidades reales de que se se forme
una alianza militar
firme entre entre rusia y china
me costaría mucho creerlo es decir se
puede haber alguna iniciativa puntual
pensemos pues en
las fuerzas de cooperación que tiene el
golfo los países árabes funcionan muy a
trompicones no hay ejercicios porque al
final tú puedes decir voy a constituir
una alianza pero si tú no lo en grasas
con ejercicios militares con muchas
relaciones personales entre los líderes
militares pues eso no funciona entonces
puede haber alguna cosa incluso formar
algún pequeño tratado alguno que permita
acordar determinadas maniobras militares
de vez en cuando pero yo no lo acabo de
ver nada grande desde luego recordemos
además que chinguen pues históricamente
ha sido también una amenaza para rusia a
toda la inmigración china en el extremo
oriente ruso que está muy poquito
poblado pues es una vista con mucho
recelo por parte del kremlin por ejemplo
ya hago cómo están las cosas ahora
digamos de estos ejercicios militares
quienes de qué se beneficia más china o
rusia quien necesita más de quién
hombre yo creo que ahora mismo
indudablemente hay una dependencia muy
clara de rusia hacia china es decir los
rusos dependen de china particularmente
si la guerra sea larga pues toda la
microelectrónica los chips los circuitos
integrados y desde luego la capacidad de
producción de la fábrica del mundo de la
industria china sería clave crucial para
que el rusia puede sostener el esfuerzo
bélico en el tiempo por tanto ahora
mismo no cabe ninguna duda de que rusia
depende completamente de china desde el
punto de vista económico logístico y a
medida que pasa el tiempo quizás militar
curiosamente hasta hacía poco pues eran
los chinos los que compraban material
ruso y todo esto todo ello se está
invirtiendo y rusia pasa a depender de
china ya bueno quiero despedirlo sin
antes preguntarle su opinión sobre el
conflicto ucraniano que evidentemente
también pues se salpica a estos vostok
esta guerra usted dijo que se podía
alargar o puede ser probablemente
también eso si sea que tanto se puede
alargar y digamos o como el panorama en
un futuro no tan lejano
en lo que en diciembre
mire yo veo dos dos grandes opciones una
es que de aquí a que acabe el invierno
vamos a poner para marzo de 2023
diciembre pues haya alcanzado un alto el
fuego no un acuerdo de paz pero sí un
alto el fuego eso sería lo ideal y lo
que nos permitiría pues bueno aliviar un
poco la situación económica en europa y
todo esto no obstante mi sensación
personal y sólo es una opinión sin mayor
valor no es un análisis es que alemania
eeuu los países occidentales se están
adoptando una posición crecientemente
dura con el kremlin y que por tanto va a
ser más improbable que se alcanza un
alto el fuego y eso implica que la
guerra puede alargarse incluso años